video bring a little sunshine to your
day you have to watch this so Las Vegas
Raiders wide receiver Devonte Adams he
was recently interviewed by one of his
biggest little fans take a look
so one of my greatest memories of my
life is going to yours to your camp and
doing a seven on seven against yes sir
so what is one of your greatest memories
in your childhood
greatest memories in my childhood I
would say when I was young maybe about
seven or eight years old I had
opportunity to meet JJ Stokes who was on
the San Francisco 49ers at the time and
that memory stuck with me because I was
the first uh professional athlete that I
met that I met and it was just a great
experience really nice guy he helped out
all of all the young kids and gave us
great advice so I probably have to say
that
picture
and that's a great picture Devonte good
answer but Jeremiah is really the star
here he's only 10 years old he's local
and he is a fan of our morning show so
if he's watching right now Jeremiah have
a good day at school hi Jeremiah go
follow him on his Instagram account
sports for free youth media he does a
lot of interviews with local sports
teams and players and I mean he racks up
a lot of views on social media
everything goes viral but he has a heart
of gold he's just the sweetest kid
you've ever met in your life so smart
and very well spoken I love that he was
running the show too he's asking the
tough questions to Devonte and he's like
can you get a picture hey can I get this
guy over there where's Derek Carr can I
get this over here yeah I love that and
he's coming and he's coming for us he's
coming for our our you're welcome it's
ready Jeremiah come on down we need all
the help we can get so if you want to
come down our morning show you're more
than welcome to it one of the greatest
memories in my childhood he's 10.
he's already got the
and good on Devonte Adams giving a given
some time to uh Jeremiah and answering
the questions Kudos all around yeah